So we get an x-ray me a traitor an expert are
What happens if we've lost a nut or a bolt?
And it's falling in one of these Jesus and can we just forget about that for now or do we have to go on are?
We don't know we're doing it properly every yeah. No, but there's no nuts involved there at the end of the day
We don't have one of their majesties prisons
We have systems that we have to go by no matter who is for we do not change the system for anybody else
There was that trolley nearby just coming doll. Thank you pizza boxes
So all the fucking work has gone in
So it's time to make my escape
Aided and abetted by prison head chef my accomplice, dal Hatfield
They'll be brilliant
This is crazy another this is absolutely ludicrous
Check there's no faults and nuts and guns and doubt. Then - laughs show some flexibility
Go to supermarkets, but enough but fuck me. This is ridiculous. This takes the biscuit and
If every single cake and tartar has to be x-rayed. I'm going through too
Morning
Two more doors to go - were out man the logistics logistics bloody hell
There's times like this. You really do know, you're in a prison yard
About time Dino Dino come through reverse up, please. Oh
Jesus Christ on my come on dean. Come on gall then honestly
We're doing in there see you later
Why are they searching us again
Why are they searching us
it'll be two seconds
Bye Gordon
It's been x-rayed sir. Yeah man down
I'm going to explain sir
With my shop opening in half an hour. It'd be quicker to tunnel our way out
what a fucking pulava
The chances are getting 5 thousand bread rolls
Or Treat the tarts out there
Excuse me
So amazing how good the food looks outside the prison I mean it's extraordinary
Listen, we may be in a pop-up. But yeah, I mean, I'm I'm hoping this stuff goes look at it
Hello welcome what comes it what can I get you amazing lemon curtains actually made by the local bricks prison
And I hear that you're working with my son your son. Yes, Jerome Samuels and his mother my god
when he focuses
He puts his head down and he gets stuck in but from little he's always he's always like looking in the kitchen everything
I just think he's just mixed the wrong company, right?
Is really usable, you know, yeah. I walked in this morning bad news. He's been suspended
There's some verbal abuse giving her me officers give us a bit of a kick I know that
That person he's in the course, you know, he's focusing what was that so where to see him
That's something I don't really do. Do you not think he needs to see Wade speak to me all the time
He can write to me. It's not somewhere that I would like to be on a regular basis
No, it's not that this time. He was thank you for coming. I appreciate it any message for him. I mean I
you tell him i  he needs
Get himself together. Yeah
I will tell him
two of these
Was worried that people wouldn't want to eat prison made food but the bad boys bakery name seems to be pulling in the punters
Very creative
There are very creative aren't they
and how does it make you  feel about mate?  That there made by prisons local last cool one? That's all I did
Yeah, that's cool. It doesn't put you off
No not at all
good
Your stuff thank you so much can only be a good thing well try and give them some chances in employment
There are no people in prison and stuff
I think you know life's a learning curve and if they can come in there and educate themself and learning skills then why not